In this problem, an engineer is
preparing to take the PE exam.
The initial costs include the PE exam
registration fees, review course, and
study materials, which the engineer
financed with a credit card.
To maintain focus while studying, the
engineer also purchases an annual supply
of the productivity enhancing chemical
caffeine-ium,
valued at $350 a year.
This is paid for in cash.
Assume the engineer studies for a 5-year
period, there is no salvage value for
the study materials, and the annual
interest rate on the credit card is 6%.
The engineer calculates the annualized
budget required to be $1,800 per year
for all exam-related expenses.
What was the engineer's initial
investment for exam fees and study
materials?
Okay.
So, hopefully, it's pretty obvious that
this is an engineering economics
problem.
One of the nice things about the PE exam
is that both the civil and environmental
reference manuals have entire sections
devoted to engineering economics.
If you search for economics in either
manual, you'll find several equations
for analyzing different types of cash
flow.
In this problem, we're given an initial
investment for the exam fees and study
materials that we need to determine,
along with an equivalent annual budget.
Whenever you're converting between a
present cost and a equivalent annual
amount, you're looking at a capital
recovery problem.
Let's write down the capital recovery
equation from the handbook.
That's going to be A
over P
equals
I
times the quantity of 1 + I raised to
the N
over
1 + I raised to the n
- 1
where P is the present worth and A is
the uniform amount per interest period.
Now that we have this laid out, let's
first calculate the capital recovery
factor.
So, I is 6%.
So, we'll do 0.06
* 1 + 0.06 is 1.06
for a 5-year period, that will be our n.
over 1.06
again to the five
- 1
Simplifying this out, we would get 0.08
over
0.3
3 8
for a final answer of about 0.2
3 6
Note that we can also use the factor
tables that are present in the handbook.
We would just need to know that we were
using the column for A over P
the table for the interest rate at 6%
and looking for the
row where n equals 5.
However, you find the capital recovery
factor
just write it down so that we can use it
in the next step.
Next, we can solve for A or the
annualized cost.
In our problem
the annual budget includes two different
costs. The first is the annualized cost
of the upfront exam expenses and the
second is the recurring annual purchase
of caffeineum.
Since the caffeineum already occurs
every year we don't need to annualize
it. It simply gets added to the annual
budget. So, we can isolate the
annualized capital cost by subtracting
the annual caffeinium expense from the
total annual budget.
So, with that in mind,
we can subtract
from
$1,800 of the annual budget
the $350
in caffeinium per year
to get 1450
per year.
Finally, all we have to do is solve for
our final unknown term, which is our
initial investment.
And this is going to come out just about
$6,144.
So, the engineer originally spent about
$6,144
on exam registration, study materials,
and the review course.
This answer is closest to answer number
two.
So, in summary, solving this problem
requires two main steps.
Selecting the correct capital recovery
equation
and recognizing
that the $350 annual caffeinium cost is
already an annual expense.
After subtracting that from the
engineer's annualized budget, you can
apply the capital recovery factor to
determine the initial investment in exam
fees and study materials. And that's it.